Mark: Alright I'm with you Wade.
Mark: Now Wade, don't pull a real Wade on me here.
Jack: Bob we got this.
Mark: Be a step above a Wade
Wade: Wait, you guys are on opposite teams. I'm with Bob.
Wade: We switched.
Mark and Jack: Oh!
Bob: Im with Wade now.
Mark: Good! Alright then.
Jack: Yeah, what're you talking about Mark?
Mark: I don't-I'm incredibly stupid.
Jack: I told you guys!
*Jack and Mark giggling*
Bob: Oh that's the ticket.
Jack: Ohhh fuck...
Mark: You don't need to convince-
Bob: That's the ticket. Actually, that's not bad.
Jack: Ohhh fuck
Mark: Wait, I'm not even playing right now.
Mark: Wait, Who's playin?
Bob: That's, uh...
Wade: Jack and I are playing.
Bob: This might actually work out, Wade. I think you got a winner here.
Wade: I think-I think this is a winner.
Mark: This is-like I said there's no way we're gonna be able to find anything in here.
Bob: *giggling* you didn't walk past him or anything but you have no fucking chance in hell.
*laughs*
Jack: What the fuck?!
Wade: Really?
Bob: This place is huge!
Mark: Yeah
Mark: But it's open, so technically you can see a lot of it
Bob: Yea maybe- maybe there should be acrobatic practice, we need to have-
Wade: Acrobatic Practice.
Jack:  Okay, tell me hot- hot or cold
Bob: Uh, where you are, almost as cold as you can be.
Wade: I would say you're pretty cold, but I ship it.
Bob: *chuckling*
Mark: What?
Mark: What does that mean?
Wade: What do you mean 'what does it mean?'
Bob: He likes your ass, Jack. That's what he means.
Wade: Yeah
Jack: Am I warmer?
Bob: Warmer than you were, warmer than you were.
Bob: Uhhhhhh, you're gettin' colder again though.
Wade: I saw ya for a second, Jack.
Mark: Oh- wait- I see him. I see him Jack.
Wade: Oh hey Jack.
Mark: I see him Jack
Bob: You see him?
Mark: Yea, I see him.
Jack: *giggle*
Bob: Oh, were you moving around, Wade?
Mark: He's gonna getcha'!
Wade: No I can't move I'm stuck!
Mark: Heeee's gonna getcha'!
Jack: He won't die!
Wade: Jack, come in! Get in for a ride!
Jack: Oi!
Mark: Oh 'I ship it' Ohhhhh I get it
Bob: Yea we were tryna' give you clues and stuff
Wade: Weeeeee!
Jack: Ya free?
Wade: You have one health- oh you have 10% health left
Jack: I'm stuck!
Wade: I still can't move.
Bob: *Laughing*
Mark: Shoot him!
Wade: Hey!
Mark: There we go.
Mark: Alright Jack
Bob: Shoooot him!
Mark: Let's not be a fool.
Wade: I just want the whole world to know, for about 20 seconds, Jack...
Wade: Was inside of me.
Mark: Yea sure. Okay.
Bob: Hot.
Jack: *laughs* Yea sure, whatever. Fuck you
Mark: Yea sure whatever
Wade: That's longer than I usually go...
Mark: Okay.
Jack: God damn Wade *chuckles*
Mark: Heh heh heh
Wade: I'm stuck looking at Jack's victory screen while I wait to be free
Bob: I'm stuck looking at a random shot of the map
Wade: This is going to be the hardest map...
Bob: I know this is gonna be awful
Jack: Bob what're you doing?! I hear banging.
Mark: You don't hear nothin'. I'm on your team, stupid fool
Jack: Ohh yea. Mark what are you doin'?
Mark: Nothin'!
Bob: Yay, we're free     Jack: Okay
Wade: Okay
Jack: Hey we should bring back the no sitting still rule for like a minute or over a minute
Mark: What happens if you're stuck? How bout' that?
Jack: Oh then you're fucked.
Bob: You have to flail around...
Wade: Give us lots of clues.
Mark: Well... It will probably be obvious when you find me...
but maybe not because you don't know the
map...
But probably
Bob: Yeah.
Bob: Also...
Bob: Eh, is this?
No, it's not this.
Wade: That's a box.
Bob: Also it's us, I'm awful at this
Wade: So far, other than knocked over vending
machines everything looks as it should
Mark and Bob: uh-huh uh-huh
Jack: One of you just walked
over me *laughs*
Bob and Wade: What?
Jack: Oh god, I left now. Mark: what? Jack: One of you walked on top of me
literally walked on me.
Wade: Well all I walked on was this, uh, scaffold thing so I think must have been you
Bob: Well I just jumped down off of a ladder
when he said that so unless...
Jack: No, no it
was before that, I left.
Wade: Oh it was a little  - so I guess, well it could've been either one of us
Jack: I was a tiny little box when you walked on top of me.
Mark: So the rule is if you're a small object you
must keep moving around, is that the
thing?
Jack: Yeah... well-
Jack: Oh! There's a whole other section.
Bob: Ah Christ
Wade: Yeah there- this map is never ending.
Mark: Not, not a whole-
Bob: Are you actually-
are you in the section that Wade was in last time
Mark:  I'm in- I'm in the main section. I'm in the- Wow!
Jack: ahaha ow!
Wade and Bob: Wow
Mark: I saw that
Jack: Jesus! Scared the shit out of me  *Mark and Jack laughing*
Wade: He was running away and it almost didn't hit him.
Mark: It was like witnessing a horrible murder
like- *screaming* BOOM!
Jack: How have I not been found yet?! Jesus Christ
Bob: Guys there's a horse in here!
Jack: Yeah
Wade: There's BLOOD in the puppy crates
Bob: Ohhh ho ho ho haha
Mark: Woah.
Wade: There's blood in all of them *upset*
Mark: I see your pain Wade.
Jack: Are you- Are you legit stuck?
Mark: I'm legit
stuck, but I see your pain Wade.
Bob: Jack, how likely do you really think it is that we'll
take him out?
Is it bad?
Jack: Not hugely likely but... like-
Jack: I'm near the general area. You should be
able to spot him pretty easily.
Mark: does anyone want-
Wade: Well he can see us-whenever I
killed Jack, he saw that.
Mark: Anyone want to play ball?
Jack: I can see one of you right now.
Mark: Yeah I can see one of you right now.
Bob: Is it- are they jumping? Is it me?
*Mark giggling*
Mark: No, it's Wade.
Wade: What it this??
Bob: So it's Wade
Mark: *Worried he's going to get caught*
Jack: What is that black ball rolling around?
Wade: You don't realize that those all were actually
from Eastern Egg's tongue face? What?
Mark: Oh okay I don't know. *chuckles*
Jack: So... they're Easter eggs?
Wade: I guess there's Easter eggs???
Mark: Man, it was so funny Wade when- when I said I could see
you your head just turned like directly
towards me * Mark and Jack chuckle* it was like a horror movie
style thing
Mark: like "HI!"
Jack: HOW HAVE YOU NOT SEEN HIM?!
Mark: Yeah how have you not seen me? You both a
bunch of idiots. You're ugly.
You're stupid. OW!
Jack: Big, fat, mean, penis faces
Mark: LOSERS! YOU'LL NEVER HAVE HAPPINESS
YOU'LL NEVER- AH! *dies* *giggles*
Wade: Oh, that didn't stand out that much,
like just a little.
Bob: It did stand out once I looked at it
Mark: Yeah
Bob: He was the wrong kind of box and he
was in another box half way.
Mark: Yeaah
Wade: Oh okay
Mark: Just a little off
Bob: Alright
Jack: I mean- I mean you got it.
Mark: Alright Jack, listen closely
Jack: Eagle eyes.
Mark: If you can hear the clacks of their
keyboards you can pick out what
direction they're going.
Bob: Ahhh yes, yes the keyboard.
Jack: Bob's just holding W
Wade: Why does this keep
happening to me?!
Jack: He stopped, he stopped.
Bob: Keyboard technique?
Mark: It's like- it's like listening to footsteps and-
Wade: NO PLEASE!
PLEASE NO
Mark: You gotta listen- uh no...
Wade: NOOO
Mark: Wade, did something happen horrible?
Jack: Those are good sounds for us, I like this.
Wade: UGH! IT'S MESHING WITH ME!
*Mark and Jack chuckling*
Jack: He's right here
Mark: Wait hang on, let me see. Let me the horror. Where you at?
Wade: IT WASN'T LIKE THIS!
Mark: Man I can't even find you Jack.
Jack: Is it where you are?
Mark: Oh I see you, I see you
okay hang on.
Jack: Oh God now I'm fucking stuck!
Bob: Um...
Wade: Yes!
Mark: Wait...
Mark: Oh, oh there you are!
Jack: Whoo!
Wade: YEEEAH!
Jack: Why would you even attempt that?!
Mark: Yeah, why did you do that??
Wade: Because I wanted
to drive around!
Mark: That wasn't going to work
Jack: You help Wade, I'm gonna go find Bob.
Bob: Wade, did you and I have the
same idea Wade?
Mark: It's gonna take a while.
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Wade, if I charge you up with my stun baton- oh no wait this
is a different game mode. I don't have that.
*Jack chuckles*
Mark: Alright, oh! You're almost out! You're almost out, You're moving!
Jack: There's no way you're this one.
*Bob laughing*
Mark: You're moving man, move!
Wade: You're not even hitting the right one.
Mark: Go for it! BE FREE!
*Bob still laughing*
Mark: Is this not workin?
Wade: Ow!
Okay, someone's hitting the right one!
*Jack laughing*
Jack: Is it me?!
*Wade screaming and dying*
Mark: I'm half hitting the right- THERE WE GO. *Wade dies*
Mark: Alright...okay. *creepy voice* Booob
Jack: Bob could you see him?
Bob: Uh, I could hear the shooting. I can not see directly. *Wade laughing*
Jack: *high pitched voice* WHERE'S BOOOOB?!
Bob: I'm in a bad way okay,
I made a mistake.
*Mark chuckling*
Mark: You've both made mistakes
*pause*
Wade: Mine... was a bigger mistake.
Mark: Uh-huh
Jack: It was a HUGE mistake
*Wade sighs*
Bob: I think mine's gonna be fine
*Wade snickering*
Mark: That doesn't sound fine.
Bob: Nah it's fine
Jack: Yeah, Wade doesn't have that much confidence in you.
Bob: It's gonna be fine okay
*Mark chuckling*
Wade: *unsure* I think he's gonna be fine.
Bob: *quoting song lyric* It's gonna be me
Jack: It's gonna be me
*Bob laughing*
Jack: Have we walked
past you yet?
Bob: I was moving around for a long time
until I made it so that I cannot move
around.
Wade: I would say that accurate.
Jack: Oh! I just teleported
Mark: It's okay I lag too. Wade's
crappy connection.
Wade: *sarcastic* Yeah, my terrible internet must be to blame
Jack: Jesus
Bob: *Mocking jack* Ah Jesus. Ah God.
Jack: JESUS
Mark: I'm trying to get a good vantage point.
Bob: ah god  yess
Jack: Have you got any clues where he is?
Bob: Uh, I can see both of you currently.
Mark: Okay
Bob: Not that that means you are terribly close
to me but i can see-
Mark: Wait, we're on
opposite sides of the map so if you can
see both of us that means you're probably-
Jack: That means you're up top.
Mark: Yeah up top and-
Wade: Ooo
Mark: Or-
Bob: Or I'm clipping
the wall
Jack: Then you can always see both of us.
Bob: I know, right
Mark: Nah but I don't
think that's it i think he was in a
position.
Let's see, in the last part, he mentioned
there was a horse...
HE MUST BE THE HORSE.
*all chuckling*
Bob: *lying* I'm definitely the horse.
Jack: THERE'S ONLY ONE OPTION.
Mark: I'VE DEDUCED IT. Bob: I actually became the horse's penis and
Bob: I'm running around now.
Mark: I DEDUCED IT. Wade: Oh no. Mark: Wait... you can move the horse... *giggles*
Wade: Oh my God you can move the horse, holy fuck
Jack: I'M A DO IT!
Bob: Noo! *laughing*
Mark: YEAH TAKE THAT BOB!
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET
Bob: NO! NOT MY HORSEY!
Jack: Is he dead now? Let's teabag him!
Wade: This a glue factory?
Mark: AHHH. okay, alright. We win right? We win? We win right?
Bob: uuuuuuhh
I, um, I lift things
Mark: ooooh
Jack: so you-
are you a forklift?
Bob: I tried to be a forklift but i uh may or
may not have succeeded
Mark: wait
Oh found him
Bob: wait come on!
Mark: wait what okay
all right well what up what up what up
Ill trust you, I trust you. Woah woah woah, don't run don't run come on
Bob: you got me
you got me
Okay, but really. I really want to know if
you can become this crane thing in the
middle
Mark: Alright, okay.
Bob: So I want to like-
Jack: So you were just fucking lying?!
Bob: No, I was- I was a yellow pushy dolly
thing.
Mark you know. He saw what I was.
Mark: Yeah, he was a yellow dolly. He was a dolly. He switched to a bucket.
Bob: I just-
I freaked out-
Mark: Try to- Try to be the horse.
Bob: Be the horse?
Mark: Yeah *Bob yelling*
*Mark laughing*
Bob: OH! OH HELP ME!
Wade: OH GOD
*Mark laughing*
Bob: Oh God!
Wade: Bob wait, just wait.
Bob: IT'S SO BAD!
*all giggling*
Bob: PLEASE HELP ME
Mark: Here take a cone.
Bob: I can't
Mark: Is it even high enough for you to get?
Mark: If you can start moving
that around it's going to be amazing.
Jack: here. here just take- Woah!
Mark and Wade: WOOAH!!
Mark: He's free! *laughing*
Jack: AHH A LEVITATING HORSE!! *mark laughing*
Jack: KILL IT! KILL IT! *mark screaming*
*Jack yelling*
Jack: IT KILLED ME! IT KILLED ME!
*mark and bob laughing*
Jack: ah, it's terrifying!
*mark and bob still laughing*
Jack: Jesus Christ
*mark and bob still laughing* (lol)
Bob: Oh my god
Jack: umm
Bob: well, see I wasn't the horse, and Mark- Mark can confirm that I was not lying
Mark: yeah he was not lying. When would Bob lie?
Bob: I never lie
Mark:oh come- are you- are you
serious here?
Jack: i may have fucked up
Mark: I definitely fucked up. I had it in my-
oh my god are you kidding me
Jack: what the fuck
it's happening? Oh No
Mark: Oh no.
Jack: help me. help.
Mark: he- help, HEEELP. Help me, I can't even - where am I?! I can't- I- WHAT HAPPENED?! *bob laughing*
Jack: OH NOOOO
*jack giggling*
Wade: this sounds like it's going exceedingly worse.
Bob: oh mark *laughing*
Mark: What happened to me?!?!?
Mark: I can't see! *bob laughing really hard*
Mark: what happened?
Jack: *groaning* ugh why?!
Jack: i'm okay, i'm okay. I might still have this.
Mark: tell me what happened because-
Bob: Mark is a vending machine standing up, but you're
inside of a laying down
vending machine
Mark: yeah I- ha- I assumed
It was something like that because I can't see
a goddamn thing.
please just end my pain.
*shooting at mark* *jack and bob laughing*
Mark: uuuugh ho ho ho ho
Wade: It's done.
Mark: oh my god.
Jack: were the two of you shooting at him?
Mark: yeah. Took two to murder.
Mark: oh that's- that's clever Jack. That's clever.
that's clever.
Jack: No it's not.
Mark: That's clever.
*jacks trying to not get caught*
Wade: Is that a clue?
Mark: Clever little boy!
Wade: clever lever
Mark: you're- you're clever!
Bob: he's a ....clever...wait a second I have a
question
Mark: what?
Bob: oh my god. wait, did do you see
just what
Jack: whaat??
Wade: how did you...
Mark: wait, what happened?
Jack: THERES A BANANA UP THERE.
Mark: woah! Bob: there's a rope that you can hang on.
Wade: oh my goodness
*Bob falls*
Bob: I fell
Mark: there's a banana up there!
Jack: yeah, there's a banana
Mark: there's a baby up there!
Jack: a banana! It's a banana
Mark: Niiiice
Jack: ho ho ho ho *laughs*
Wade: I saw you Jack. I saw you over there.
*Mark laughing*
Bob: wait you saw? I was like
oh no, I feel like he's laughing at me.
Mark: uh Wade,
er- Jack that was not a good move.
Mark: IT'S TIME TO STOP JACK!
IT'S TIME TO STOP.
*Mark and Jack laughing*
*all laughing*
Bob: Wait, were you a clock?
Jack: I was then-
Wade: He was something and then I shot and blew up
all of the boxes, and then he was a clock.
Jack: I was a pallet
Mark: Yeah he was a pallet
Jack: You were standing on me
*Wade groans*
Bob: Oh okay
Mark: Yeah you guys were like dancing on his
face. It was awesome.
Bob: God damn it
Jack: And then you left. I- well I
wanted to move but couldn't
because then you would've seen me.
Wade: Oh
Jack: *Demonic like voice*
Kick off your Sunday shoes
*Mark giggles*
Wade: Wait, Bob are you *giggles*
Bob: I'm not
doing anything. Leave me-
Jack: Whenever Bob tries to do something sneaky
he gets really quiet.
Wade: Uh oh.
Bob: Leave me alone
Wade: Uh
Mark: Okay- Woah, what
was-
Jack: *laughing* Hi
*giggles* hi (probably got caught)
*shooting sounds*
Bob: Hang on, hang on.
I'm just experimenting.
Bob: I'm assuming it's me that you are seeing and saying 'hello' to.
Jack: *giggles* yes
Bob: yes. Hi
*jack laughing*
Jack: what are you doing?
Bob: I'm- I'm experimenting. Hang on.
Jack: Experimenting??
Bob: Oh no there's not one down
here. Shit, hang on.
Let me to the other end.
Let me go to the other end. I'll stay- I'll
stay in 'T' form
Mark: Oh, Hi. Oh hi Bob.
Jack: *Shoots gun* oh sorry! sorry. Shot my gun on accident.
Bob: I feel like- I feel like I'm
playing this game wrong.
Mark: What are you trying to do Bob?
Bob: I want to see if I can
become the crane still, and I drop down on top of it.
Mark: *unsure* I don't think you can
Jack: I highly doubt you can become the crane.
Mark: Yeah.
*bob fails* *grunts*
Mark: *mocking bob* EHH, ma elbows.
Bob: Well that didn't work
Mark: Ma neck
Jack: (talking to bob) here, you go hide again
I'll go find Wade.
Mark: Alright, fine, FINE.
Bob: I'll go try and a
spot. Um...
Mark: Alright.
Wade: *laughing*
Mark: Wade-
Bob: *chuckles* sorry Wade.
Wade: It's okay
Mark: wait, what?
*Bob, Wade and Jack laughing*
Mark: Ah! Spotted! Top- Top corner
Bob: I'm going to try to find a-
Mark: Something back there.
Mark: I'm watchin'
Jack: One of you is-
Mark: Somethin'
back there.
Jack: Or not. I can- I can push everything.
I don't trust it anymore
Mark: I'm watchin'.
LIKE A HAWK.
Bob: You still can't push
props.
Mark: I got eeeeyes on.
Mark: Eyes on.
Jack: Where the fuck did you go?!
You were right here.
Mark: He's still in there.
He hasn't moved. He hasn't gone away.
Bob: I may become a tiny box.
I may have become a tiny box Bob
Mark: Woah, I saw movement out
of my right corner in that back storage area. I'M COMING
FOR YOU LATER.
*Bob chuckles*
Jack: The fuck...
Mark: I saw that...
Jack: Well he said 'Hi Wade'
when he came over here.
Mark: AH! oh hi *giggles*
Mark: *laughs* he was just in T-pose back there
Bob: Oh you guys didn't find Wade?
Bob: oh fuck
Mark: Wade! Oh!
Bob: I thought I brought you right to him.
Mark: Oh, that's Wade!
Mark: Okay! *laughs*
Jack: Oh
Mark: Wait hang on.
Jack: Well, I didn't hit anything.
Mark: Someone's up there someone is but.
Jack And he's awfully quiet!
Mark: Eh
Bob: I'm not awfully quiet.
Mark: Aw shit
Bob: You're awfully quiet
Jack: Hahahahaha
Bob: God damn it. I was-
Mark: Oh geez
Mark: I shot you right in the head execution-style
Jack: So it's Wade who was in T-pose!
Mark: they were both T-pose
Wade: So, Bob and I had the same idea to start the round.
Everyone: *laughs*
Wade: We both were the same thing!
Bob: Were you behind me, when that happened, is that why you said that?
Wade: I was trying to be and then I just dropped down and ran!
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: While they were looking at you, I maneuvered around them to get to the back room.
Bob: Apparently, we need to mix up the strategies a little bit Wade.
Mark: Oh wampa-NOO!!
Jack: Ah come on man!
Mark: AW!! But-it's-I- what else was I supposed to do?
Mark: God Damn it!
Jack: I'm alone!
Mark: HAAAAAAAAh
Jack: I'M ALL ALONE!!!
Mark: *starts singing* I'm all alone! I got no one shfkld ANA!
Jack: With out me!
Everyone: *starts singing* kkjhnsdruifhernf
Jack: IN SO LONG!!! I'M ALL OUT OF LOVE! I'M SO LOST WITH OUT YOU!!
Mark: Hey how did that song go?
that I was singing earlier?
Bob: Oh my god. Can you become...this?
Jack: *starts singing* DAAAAAAAA, no.
Mark: Yeah I can't remember how it went.
Jack: SHIT!
Bob: What were you singing, the Lord of the Rings song?
Mark: no no no
Mark: Hai yai YAI OH OH ai!
Jack: *joins in* OH OH ai *laughs*
Bob: Oh, is that that Enya song?
Mark: Something like that! *laughs*
Mark: The grumps, like, we're doing it on their most
recent episode and i just have been able
to stop doing it ever since, so hai yai YAI OH AI!
Mark: Jack you're gonna, die yai YAI
Jack: AHHH!!
Jack: WHY!!!!
Mark: You done fucking goofed bruh!
Mark: You did the same thing I tried to do its humerus.
Bob: You see him Wade or-
Mark: I don't know how you can't not see him!
Jack: Jesus guys!
Bob: I don't understand.
Jack: I don't think any of them are near me .
Jack: where did all the tiny props go?
Mark: Jack, I don't like your disgui-yai-Yai-OH-AI *laughs*
Jack: YAI-OH-AI *laughs*
Jack: Wait, where are they?
Bob: I feel like we look really dumb Wade.
Mark: yeah they're, oh wow, yeah wow.
Wade: Yeah I think we do too.
Bob: Oh.
Mark: *starts laughing*
Bob: Hey buddy!
Jack: Come on! Give me another chance! Mark wasn't here!
Mark: Na na na na, don't give- don't give- nonono don't do it don't do it.
Bob: You want something?
Jack: I can't even see anything.
Bob: Here friend, here.
Jack: I don't know if I can grab anything.
Jack: I'm pressing E everywhere!
Mark: Yeah you can't do it Jack.
Wade: There's a box right in front of you.
Bob: Here I'll put it on top of you so you got it- Oh it's inside of you.
Mark: Yeah, just end his pain!
Bob: I didn't mean to penetrate you Jack.
Mark: End the-end the suffering, just end it. Oh
Mark: wow. What the hell happened?
Jack: OW!
Everyone: *starts laughing*
Wade: Bob you killed him with the box.
Jack: Fucks sake!
Mark: Wow, that was brutal.
Bob: At least I'm not the only one who died like an idiot!
Mark: Ye-yeah
Jack: You died for the round even started.
Mark: Yeah
Bob: Whatever
Mark: Hmmmmmm
Jack: What happens if you get stuck with Mark.
Mark: I don't know, COME ON MAN i'm trying
want to play the game just as badly as
you!
Mark: I-I just take it's
it's harder for me.
Wade: That didn't work as well as I'd hoped it would.
Jack: Why? *laughs*
Mark: I don't know, something about brain damage.
I don't know.
Jack: Yeah, that's true.
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: I believe that in a heart beat.
Mark: Ok Hublelur*slurp*
Bob: Diggity darn it
Bob: Son of a bitch damn hole
Mark: I'll look up top.
Bob: Oh
Jack: I surveyed-AH-I see one of them, they're tiny.
Bob: Nope.
Mark: Where at?
Wade: I wanted to swing the wrecking ball so badly, but it didn't work.
Jack: Sorry, had to.
Bob: God damn it. I keep
stuff that's not working this map is
really frustrating.
Mark: Yeah, it's hard to get like
Jack: I got a lucky ball, it says you got a suicide bomb.
Bob: well...
Wade: Bob, whatever you were, don't feel bad that I live longer than you.
Bob: It's actually not a bad spot Wade, I
don't know if they're ever gonna look there.
Jack: Bob, I'm sorry for shooting you so quick, I get paranoid that I'm not gonna find you
again and I want to win.
Bob: I mean I was a tiny little can, but I did not
intend to run around I was trying to get
on top of the shelves of of uh of boxes
but you can't get on or in those
anywhere
Mark: Hmm
Wade: Even if they do look here Bob I think I blend in very well.
Bob: Yeah I think
you're really camouflaged.
Mark: Are you something small or big?
Jack: We got him-we got him Mark.
Mark: Wha-
Bob: You got a good- you got a good suit of armor.
Mark: SCANNING!!
Jack: Scanning for Wade.
Bob: Got a real thick skin.
Mark: *deep voice* Scanning the environment.
Jack: You got thick skin.
Mark: Thick skin, ok, thick skin. What's got-what's thick? Damn, he thick, so what is he?
Wade: Yeah, well, I'm about how Bob would describe me I guess.
Bob: *starts laughing*
Mark: He thick?
Jack: Thick?
Mark: Thick?
Jack: He thick tho?
Bob: Think meaner.
Mark: Dat thick tho?
Bob: *starts laughing*
Mark: Oh, aw, I saw that banana fall down I was like HUH!!!
oh okay.
Jack: hahaha
Wade: Was it a thick banana?
Bob: You get that banana.
Mark: You know that banana thick.
Jack: I got that B.
Mark: That's actually funny because I went to the store and I wasn't gonna buy a banana, but this banana was like a hybrid double banana. It was super thick and extra girthy so I bought it and um uh that's the end of my story.
Mark: That's- that's the end of my story. Story ends there.
Bob: Mark, you know what, you moved out to La, you became a huge success and dropped that huge double banana story  on us, it's like, I don't even know who you are anymore man.
Wade: You've changed Markiplur
Mark: Well, that banana changed me, in more ways that one.
Wade: I bet it would.
Jack: That's a life changing banana.
Bob: Let's talk about how girthy something is and then say-
Mark: Oh, Hi! Hello!
Wade: Oh, Why?
Wade: Can't we talk?
Bob: Wait, Wade can sell me out hang on. He'll sell me out.
Wade: Yeah I'll tell you I'll take you to Bob.
Mark: Bob's dead!
Bob: I'm not dead!
Wade: You thought Bob was dead but-
Mark: Why can't I kill you?
Bob: It was all a clever trick.
Mark: There you go!
Jack: Where are you?
Everyone: *starts laughing*
Mark: That was a good move, that was a good move, good move Wade.
Wade: Now you get why I said I was as Bob would described me?
Mark: that was a good- Thick THo!! He thick!
Jack: Where was he?
Mark: He was a-
Wade: I was a bald old man!
Mark: Yeah he was a bald man with thick...something. He was-damn he- damn
Bob: No, I said he had thick skin.
Wade: That horse takes after me if you know what I mean.
Mark: I don't-what are you talking about?
Jack: You have hooves?
Wade: Uh-yeah
Wade: I was born with-
Bob: *singing the earlier song that Mark and Jack were singing*
Wade: Who says hoof?
Jack: Aw Shite balls.
Bob: *Bubble sounds*
Wade: hey Bob, I found them.
Mark: You didn't find nothing!
Bob: *laughing*
Mark: What are you talking about?
Mark: Actually what are you talking about it's making me nervous.
Wade: There's one of them in this corner, right behind you Bob.
Wade: There was boxes bouncing all over the place.
Mark: Wait no there weren't.
Mark: Naw-uh
Mark: HEY LOOK AT ME, LOOK AT ME!!
Jack: *laughing*
Mark: Damn it.
Bob: Got him!
Mark: I tried to- I tried to distract.
Mark: Jack!
Mark: It just didn't work.
Jack: You tried Mark.
Mark: I tried.
Jack: OOOHHHH!
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: See, I'm not-  I'm not
Mark: I'm not hidden.
Jack: No.
Mark: I'm pretty out in the open.
Bob: What is this? I wanna be this.
Jack: I mean, you're SODA hidden.
Mark: Oh come on man! *laughs* come on!
Bob: Really?
Wade: Wait, did you say SODA hidden? Are you the vending machine again?
Mark: No, not-
Jack: I said SORTA! SWORDA!
Everyone: SORTA
Mark: Yeah, SORTA.
Wade: He's a penis!
Bob: Yeah I haven't seen any swords. That's not helpful at all.
Bob: Are there swords?
Mark: It's almost like he's not trying to help you!
Bob: When would I have checked the entire map, Jack?
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: You've been here the Whole time.
Jack: I'm dead!
Mark: Man-
Wade: If you guys know where he is, he's very dead.
Mark: You guys-one of you looked right at me.
Mark: Just a second ago.
Bob: Must have been Wade.
Wade: I've been in this corner, so if it's me, it was in this corner.
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: You have to face him!
Bob: I don't Understand.
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: Clocks have faces.
Bob: I don't understand.
Mark: Man, ah man, *sniff sniff* Ah you guys smell so good.
Mark: I lo-I just I love watching you guys work.
Mark: It's just an inspiration.
Bob: I don't get it.
Jack: You're SODA close to him!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: SWORDA CLOSE
Bob: Now you're just mixing hints.
Bob: Now you're just- now you're just saying different hints.
Mark: Yeah
Wade: He said SODA again.
Mark: HI!!!! *laughs*
Wade: What was he Bob?
Bob: He was a little soda can.
Wade: I KNEW HE SAID SODA!!
Bob: Do for so long!!
Wade: I knew he said soda!
Bob: How the fuck did you do that?
[Outro]